[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
n'interprétez les actions qui sont
intéressés à la fois contre novak on
vous fait un certain nombre de médecins
il a honte tu vas plus difficile l'accès
à un tribunal est donc à faire mettre en
difficulté la mobilisation des bri à
bâle
les citoyens et qui dit difficulté de
mise sur des droits par les citoyens
d'une volonté également de faire l'inra
une profession dont le rôle est
précisément le rôle majeur protégé d'un
couple qui divorce
regardez les tensions en prison si
défendre chacun et permettent à tous
même y accéder à la justice c'est
remplir cette mission at on peur du jour
et nuit du dimanche au lundi 8 heures à
8 heures et être avant cassé quoi
financer une caisse de retraite qu'il
coûte baa n'auront contribué
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
solidaires a donc tous les retraités
quant aux féminines en réalité en suit
des cours qui sont des bété et ils ont
la part achevé par une attaque qui a
financé un frontal et les choses sont
assez difficiles avant la profession
travaille énormément beaucoup d'heures
souvent le samedi
régulièrement je vais ce que vaut tenir
trente huit ans parce que beaucoup
d'entre eux n'ont pas de revenus très
importants de leur vie médian de la
profession d'avocat ses 43 mille euros
annuels puisque les 50% de la porte il
ya eu moins de quarante mille feux comme
on le dit le répète à l'envi notre
caisse elle est une trace de l'hiver
elle est beaucoup plus solidaires que ce
que va nous faire cette réforme elle est
totalement viens je roule et
excédentaires elle ne peut il ya on n'a
personne bout
nous avons donc on se dit que c'est
vraiment un coup est destinée à faire
disparaître les plus faibles d'entre
nous est souvent les buses lune entre
hong sang soo qui s'occupait plus de
faibles donc que va pas dire que c'est
l'objectif mais en tout cas ce sera les
faits
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
l'automne
au combat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]